[Musica]
chi di voi ha la tecnologia non sto
parlando della paura che a mia madre
quando guarda lo smartphone non
comprende bene le notifiche parlo
proprio di la paura quella vera quella
che fa battere il cuore quella che fa
sudare freddo state le manchi voi ha
paura della tecnologia qualcuno in fondo
bene pensavo peggio per voi pochi
sappiate che la vostra paura
parzialmente infondata
questo perché è più la non
consapevolezza nel utilizzare uno
strumento tecnologico che è nato per
colmare dei vostri desideri e tramite
l'utilizzo di un computer di un'altra ma
facciamo veramente bene a non
preoccuparci della tecnologia
faccio questa domanda perché in realtà
dovete sapere che esistono determinate
tecnologie che sono per forza governate
da un soggetto remoto che molti casi non
sappiamo nemmeno che esiste e e di
questo soggetto remoto noi ci stiamo
totalmente confinando cioè ci crediamo e
non sappiamo che viste e b
speriamo che questo soggetto del moto
non faccia danni perché vi parlo di
questo di questo rischio
ve lo spiego meglio con un esempio che
fa capire molto bene in far capire
meglio quello che sto parlando
esiste una serie tv americana mister rob
bellissima parla di eliot un hacker
psicopatico che sfrutta le proprie
competenze informatiche per combattere
il sistema per combattere una
determinata multinazionale in una città
bellissima come a new york
cosa succede che nella prima puntata
della seconda stagione
eliot e
i seguaci di eliot fanno una cosa
bellissima
una parte della prima puntata inizia che
c'è questo avvocato di questa
multinazionale che esce dalla doccia
esce dalla doccia e si accorge che la
casa è fredda ci sono 12 gradi corre
verso il termostato termostato è un
praticamente un tablet
questo perché questa abitazione una
cosiddetta smart house cioè quelle case
governate da centraline informatiche che
governano tutti i processi di vita della
casa dalla luce né riscaldamento dalla
saracinesca e quant'altro questa ragazza
si avvicina verso il termostato esposta
la temperatura su temperature più
confortevoli e niente torna sui 12 grate
riprova a spostare la temperatura su i
12 gradi e niente torna indietro
questo perché in senso senza capire il
motivo è un certo punto mentre insiste
insiste insiste la casa impazzisce e si
iniziano accendere le luci ad
intermittenza squillami telefoni ma
dall'altra parte non c'è nessuno
musica a tutto volume si accende la tv e
addirittura la serranda nella
saracinesca del garage si alza e si
abbassa come impazzita
inizia a suonare l'allarme sono allarme
è questa persona corre per di inserire
l'allarme perché il rumor è troppo forte
inserisci il codice il codice non lo
prende
nella totale disperazione sfuma la scena
su lei che si è messa un piumino perché
la fine in casa ci sono quattro gradi e
tramite lo smartphone chiama
l'assistenza per venire a risolvere il
problema ma quelli dell'assistenza
tecnica gli rispondono che
purtroppo deve aspettare una settimana
perché hanno troppe chiamate perché non
è un problema che ha soltanto lei e che
pertanto è costretta ad abbandonare
l'appartamento perché il problema non si
può risolvere in questo momento è
costretta ad abbandonare l'appartamento
perché l'appartamento letteralmente
impazzito e soprattutto non ci sono le
temperature idonee per la vita di un
umano lì dentro allora questo avvocato
cosa fa chiama nella un'auto blu scena
sfuma
questo autista carica la valigia nel
frattempo nello sfondo c'è ancora la
casa impazzita e luci che varia
intermittenza la serranda che sia presa
bassa e la macchina va via
contemporaneamente la macchina va via e
avvicina se vicino alla mano sconosciuta
alla maniglia di questo appartamento e
appena tocca la parte da questa maniglia
tutto smette le luci non sono che
impazzite l'allarme smette di suonare la
serranda e perfettamente quel posto
la porta si apre eppure questa persona
non è l'avvocato di questa
multinazionale è un soggetto terzo più
persone iniziano a salire le scale di
questo appartamento e altro non è che la
sorella di eliot che grazie ai suoi
amici hanno violato la centralina della
smarthouse costringendo il proprietario
di coda casa abbandonare l'appartamento
per occuparlo praticamente ecco se
questo vi può risultare impossibile al
giorno d'oggi vi sbagliate
questo perché non so se lo sapete
esistono già ce lo vogliono già vendere
queste tecnologie per le nostre
abitazioni e non è difficile pensare e
quello che vi ho appena raccontato
potrebbe tranquillamente essere
l'evoluzione dei ladri di appartamento
cioè queste persone
non si allenano più a da a forzare le
serrature a tagliare le ringhiere o
quant'altro ma faranno il loro scouting
il loro allenamento sul come violare
sistemi di smart house per costringerci
ad abbandonare l'appartamento
semplicemente aprire le porte di casa
nostra con noi magari dentro è una cosa
inimmaginabile se ci pensiamo ver
inimmaginabile come quest altra notizia
riportata dal wall street journal e
tantissimi altri
altre testate giornalistiche americane
dove sostanzialmente si documenta il
fatto che è un contractor esterno quindi
un consulente esterno della national
security agency americana quindi le nei
sei servizi segreti informatici
americani il computer di questo
consulente è stato violato e sono stati
rubati tutti i documenti segreti
dell'agenzia di sicurezza americana
quindi cose molto importanti
grazie all'antivirus un paradosso
chiunque è seduto qui pensa che
l'antivirus serve per difenderci da
questi attacchi informatici difendersi
da questi virus
peccato che proprio perché l'antivirus
funziona con un soggetto terzo remoto
non è impossibile pensare che questo
soggetto terzo remoto vada a modificare
volutamente quelli installazioni di quel
antivirus per permettere un attaccante
di fare ponte da aden da fuori ha dentro
questo computer passando per l'anti
virus o qualsiasi altro software questa
persona abbia installato a bordo proprio
perché quel software non è governato
solo dall'utente finale ma anche da chi
garantisce questo servizio
inimmaginabile anche questo
inimmaginabile anche questa notizia non
so quanti di voi l'hanno già letta e
grazie a una divulgazione di wikileaks
si è scoperto che è sempre al national
security agency non sono manco loro
pesanti ha sviluppato un software in
grado di entrare nelle case di tutti gli
americani di tutti gli europei nelle
case che hanno installato un determinato
modello di smart tv della samson quelle
con webcam e microfono integrato un
software talmente sviluppato bene che
permette di accendere il microfono e
telecamera anche a tv spenta
la scusa è stata quella che l'enel si è
sviluppato questo programma trovando
vulnerabilità informatiche su questo
smartphone su questo smart tv per
esigenze di sicurezza nazionale però
pensate voi siete comodamente a casa
vostra a cenare a parlare con vostro
figlio che vi racconta cosa ha fatto il
giorno prima scuola e qualcuno magari
donald trump vista ascoltando le vostre
conversazioni per queste in sicurezza
nazionale voi non ve ne accorgete
inimmaginabile ma cosa ancor più grave
e qui c'è un fattore umano che incide
molto
avete mai sentito parlare di wana craik
buona krhin e stato uno dei degli
attacchi informatici dei malware
informatici prodotti che ha fatto più
danni larga scala sostanzialmente a
marzo di quest'anno viene individuata
una vulnerabilità informatica su i
comunissimi sistemi operativi che
utilizziamo quotidianamente quindi
windows 10 8 xp 7 e anche quelli lato
aziendale quindi quelli serve la
microsoft individua e rilascia subito un
aggiornamento per mitigare questo
attacco informatico quindi una volta
scoperto tempo almeno 24 ore
la microsoft rilascio di aggiornamento
questo aggiornamento praticamente stato
ignorato dalla quasi totalità degli
amministratori di sistema e degli utenti
finali
fino a quando siamo arrivati a maggio
dello stesso anno che aziende persone
ospedali addirittura alcuni pronto
soccorsi non riuscivano a ricevere le
persone le emergenze proprio perché non
andavano i sistemi informativi in realtà
come fabbriche con fabbriche della
nissan governo non riuscivano più a
produrre automobili una determinata
fabbrica è stata chiudere che produceva
auto per mister no è stata chiusa cinque
giorni essere chiusi cinque giorni
quindi non produrre più auto mobili per
cinque giorni equivale un danno
economico veramente grossissimo tutto
perché perché ci siamo
parlo dell'uomo si è dimenticato di
questa criticità non aggiornato i
sistemi un in alcuni contesti una
banalità ma almeno non ha nemmeno
valutato la possibilità di farlo se ne
completa ha completamente ignorato la
tematica ma è così difficile trovare
sistemi vulnerabili cioè attaccanto no
come fa individuare sistemi vulnerabili
è abbastanza facile in realtà
dovete sapere che esiste una piattaforma
si chiama shodan lei lo chiamo il google
della sicurezza informatica praticamente
mediante ricerche puntuali vi fa vedere
cosa è disponibile su internet con
quella determinata caratteristica potete
chiedere per esempio webcam che non
hanno credenziali oppure webcam con
credenziali admin admin o sistemi
esposti su internet accessibili senza
autenticazione
io ho fatto una ricerca molto semplice
sudan questa è la esattamente come lo
tra parentesi è gratuito potete usarlo
anche a voi gratuito fino a qualche
richiesta una centinaia di richieste ha
detto fammi vedere
e questa la situazione al 17 settembre
di quest'anno
quanti sistemi sono vulnerabili a wanaka
e dopotutto il casotto che è accaduto
bene 900 più di 954 mila sistemi
vulnerabili in tutto il mondo al 17
settembre 2017 puro masochismo
praticamente cioè c'è stato tutto quello
che vi ho appena raccontato e c'è gente
che ancora espone sistemi vulnerabili e
quindi potenzialmente sono the vast
della stabile sono vanno fatti in
frantumi questi sistemi se presi sotto
attacco in italia come siamo messi bene
ma non benissimo questa ricerca puntuale
sull'italia ci sono sette in più di
7.000 sistemi ancora vulnerabili e
l'ultimo in lista è una nota università
italiana
questo per farvi capire che
quando si parla di sicurezza informatica
è molto importante non limitarci nel
parlare soltanto di tecnologia il
fattore chiave dei tutti concetti di
sicurezza informatica è e rimarrà sempre
l'uomo per due motivi
e l'uomo che sviluppa questi sistemi sia
l'hardware che il software ed è l'uomo
che li utilizza quindi se abbiamo un
buco in questa catena avremmo dei
problemi gravissimi di sicurezza
informatica
quindi è inutile investire milioni di
euro in tecnologia se il problema è
l'utonto cioè l'utente tonto l'utente
non sostanzialmente formato però
purtroppo quando noi utilizziamo quel
maledetto smartphone o tablet è come se
spegniamo spegnessimo il cervello cioè
non ci facciamo caso facciamo un uso
sconsiderato della tecnologia
se non avete ancora qualche dubbio a
riguardo questa è la prova definitiva
esiste un profilo twitter che è riposta
le fotografie degli utenti sempre su
twitter che fotografano volutamente la
propria carta di credito fronte e retro
perché poverini ancora il sicuro col
mancasse uno sforzo in più da parte
dell'attaccante
poi la cosa bella è che nei commenti se
sottoscritto la grazia per la nuova
playstation 4
il problema qual è che fin quando
esistono perché da queste sono eccezioni
però l'uso non come dire congruo della
tecnologia porta a seri problemi di
sicurezza informatica e seri problemi
sicurezza informatica non vanno risolti
con dell'altra tecnologia
dovete sapere che questo signore ha
affermato tantissimi anni fa una frase
bellissima ci sono solo due cose che
sono infinite l'universo e la stupidità
umana e per quanto riguarda l'universo
non ne sono nemmeno sicuro per quanto
concerne la sicurezza informatica
purtroppo albert einstein ha veramente
tanto ragione
e allora cosa dobbiamo fare per essere
più sicuri noi per essere anche
trasmettere sicurezza dobbiamo partire
dal basso
dobbiamo formare appartiene al basso
considerando anche i nostri figli dalle
scuole un'educazione volta proprio al
contesto di uso congo della tecnologia
perché se usiamo modo la tecnologia se
possediamo la tecnologia quindi siamo
certi di quello che stiamo facendo con
quel determinato strumento informatico
il rischio di compiere corbellerie è
sicuramente molto più basso e dobbiamo
insegnare soprattutto alle persone che
per lavoro trattano informazioni
classificate o personali o riservate
anche della vita e tutti i giorni a un
uso consapevole di quello strumento
informatico dove sono contenuti
tutte queste informazioni perché
soltanto con la consapevolezza
dell'utilizzo della tecnologia riusciamo
a vivere in un mondo più sicuro grazie
[Applauso]